Petey chatted with the newly crowned
pageant queen exclusively on Friday
about her groundbreaking win for the
LGBT community I'm on cloud nine I'm
ready to go to Miss America and I'm
really happy to have made history I am
definitely the first openly gay Miss
Missouri and the first woman to go into
the Miss America competition openly gay
Aaron O'Flaherty took home the title of
Miss Missouri Saturday after winning
overall in all areas of competition the
23 year old beauty queen plans to spend
her reign promoting a cause that hits
close to home
when I was 13 I lost one of my best
friends to suicide and it was through
the grieving process that I realized
that there were warning signs and maybe
this could have been prevented
so I'm now an advocate for the American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention Aaron
came out at 18 and it looks like she's
now a trailblazer for lesbian women in
the pageant system in the past few days
I've received several messages from
other contestants that are out in other
states so that's awesome to hear that
maybe I won't even be the only one going
to Miss America this year openly lesbian
so that is really exciting I saw most of
my success after I came out because I
was able to present myself as exactly
who I am
watch Erin compete for Miss America on
September 11th in Atlantic City New
Jersey
you